hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein rezept welche sich
schon bei der galileo sendung gemacht
habe und zwar den sp brezel salat also
man ins tor salat aber bisher bin ich
habe unten eine salz plätzen schicht wie
karamellisiert wird darüber kommt eine
frischkäse creme und darüber erdbeeren
mit einem guss also wirklich total
lecker und wirklich sehr einfach vor
allem kann man das in so einer schönen
großen glas vor machen also eine
auflaufform die wir eben auch in den
ofen stecken kann legen kann und dann
kann man eben ganz viele menschen damit
satt bekommen bzw glücklich machen denn
es ist ja ein dessert steige jetzt mal
die zutaten für die brezel schicht und
zwar hab ich jetzt hier vorne bereits
200 gramm salzbrezeln 130 gramm butter
und 100 gramm zu kommen und es geht
jetzt auch ganz einfach ich gebe jetzt
butter und zucker in einem topf und
schaltet den herd an damit die butter
schmelzen der zucker sich so ein
bisschen auflösen kann
und in der zwischenzeit kein schon die
brezel in die auflaufform geben und sie
so ein bisschen kleiner und das mache
ich jetzt hier mit einem stampfer und
wenn ihr keinen habt gebt ihr die gretel
in den sprit er in einem gebäude und
verstand wieder mit einem ausrutscher
bricht jetzt ins tal egger und vor allem
kann man sich das so gar nicht richtig
vorstellen wie das schmeckt bald grippe
mit erdbeeren schmeckten zutage
jetzt habe ich den herd ausgestellt
jetzt kommen die brezeln hier mit rein
man könnte es jetzt natürlich auch in
der auflaufform alles vermischen
aber dann macht man die auflaufform ein
bisschen dreckig und ich möchte schon
dass die am ramsauer bleibt deswegen
jetzt kurz hier drin vermischen
und der zucker kannte sich jetzt
natürlich nicht ganz auflösen denn die
mutter hatte nicht so viel feuchtigkeit
deswegen kommen das ist noch mal eine
auflaufform und darf in den ofen
karamellisieren
von der konsistenz sind jetzt die preds
und stücke sehr weich weil sie eben
jetzt feucht sind aber jetzt im ofen
wird es gleich richtig stinkig und die
briten kommen jetzt bei 210 grad bei
ungefähr 15 minuten in den backofen
ihr solltet ihr auf jeden fall
beobachten
die brezel sind jetzt fertig und
natürlich sehen sie auch schon abgekühlt
und hier sieht man ganz deutlich dass
die oberfläche schön karamellisiert ist
jetzt werde ich dafür schon mal die
krähen herstellen das wird ist eine
frisch käsecreme das heißt die brezeln
sind leicht fällt sich die frischkäse
film ist leicht 20 aber im endeffekt ist
es ein süßes dessert uns passt wirklich
alles super zueinander
dafür brauche ich 400 gramm frischkäse
da nämlich frischkäse in doberan stufe
200 g schlagsahne 100 gramm puderzucker
etwas vanille extrakt und sun abfahrt
und einem spritzer zitronensaft und es
geht jetzt auch ganz schnell
in dem jetzt die fahne da kommen jetzt
erst frisch käse mit dazu dann auch der
puderzucker und bonaparte und beim
seiner tat nämlich immer pro 100 gramm
masse einen teelöffel das als 600 m und
nahmen sechs teelöffel
dann etwas verloren extrakt und einen
spritzer zitronensaft
jetzt wird das ganze gut miteinander
verrührt und wird so steif geschlagen
als er müsste als vorher nicht die creme
die sahne steif schlagen sondern es gibt
alles zusammen
und die krise streicht jetzt auf den
vollständig abgekühlten boden das ist
auch ganz wichtig denn ansonsten würde
es eher wieder flüssig werden an gut
glatt streichen
jetzt kann ich auch gleich die dritte
schicht zubereiten mit den erdbeeren
dafür ständig dass das sehr aber kurs in
den kühlschrank und bereits schon mal
die zutaten vor ich habe schon alle
zutaten für den guss ich brauche dafür
500 gramm erdbeersaft einpackte magazine
30 vom speisestärke und etwa 500 gramm
erdbeeren
ihr könnt natürlich den bus auch mit
einem fertigen tortenguss machen aber
ich finde man kann sich das immer ganz
gut sparen nimmt einfach stärke und hier
habe ich jetzt noch magazine das ist im
pflanzliches studie mit
man kann jetzt auch nur mit stärker
arbeiten dann wird aber der große er
trieb und nicht so durchsichtig und mit
aktivierter eben schon durchsichtig
jetzt kommen die zutaten in einen topf
und bevor ich diese anstelle also den
herbst kommt die agile mit rein und die
stärke auf das wäre jetzt klümpchen frei
verhört bei der akn ist es jetzt ganz
wichtig dass sie gleich zwei minuten
lang sport und gekocht wird
denn das ist so eine fehlerquelle die
häufig vorkommt wenn man die ich zwei
minuten sprudelnd kochen lassen laut
koch rennen lässt dann findet die akad
ihnen nicht um bleibt einfach für sich
deswegen stelle ich jetzt den herd an
das aufkochen und dann wirklich zwei
minuten lange köcheln lassen
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt
schon mal die erdbahn schneiden
das geht jetzt entweder mit einem messer
ganz schnell oder ihr nehmen zum
beispiel einen eierschneider da legt ihr
die erdbeeren rein und schneidet sie
oder falls ihr habt uns geht es hier
auch ganz gut aber es hängt immer so ein
bisschen weil der schneider ja nur
drehte hat und keine scharfen klingen
oder falls ihr habt könnt ihr auch einen
erdbeer schneider nehmen
das lohnt sich eigentlich nur wenn man
wirklich viel mit erdbeer schreiben
macht und dann finde ich es ganz okay
das hat nämlich richtige klingen und
dann wird die erdbeeren nicht zerdrückt
den kuss kann ich jetzt mit den
erdbeeren vermischen dann könnte auch
ein bisschen ab und dann kann man auch
gleich über das was er darüber geben
der kurze sitzt nur noch lauwarm und
jetzt kann ich ihnen über das ist sehr
darüber lernen und gut verteilen
im prinzip schon fertig aber ich muss
natürlich noch kühlen so etwa zwei
stunden
jetzt kommt zu meinen kühlschrank und
später körpers gleich probieren jetzt
gespannt
jetzt ist es eher bereit jetzt kannst du
direkt probieren alles gespannt ich
kennst du eigentlich schon ihre menschen
genießen auch schon gegessen und ich
muss auch sagen das war glaube ich so
der favorit unter den ganzen länge leo
rezept halt sehr leicht schmeckt ja auch
aber ich also mein favorit war
eigentlich mehr dieser dieser riesen
riegel
das ist echt läge hier bitteschön
dankeschön
also hier ich mein ja sieht lustig aus
aber es ist wirklich dieser geschmack
ist king ja diese salzige süße erdbeeren
mit dem brunch mit der creme und ich
finde da passt einfach alles
die süße vor allem und das seewasser gut
vorbereiten kann
und man kann auch noch mitnehmen wenn
man eingeladen ist und vor allem ist so
eine überraschung
es kann sich keiner vorstellen so genial
mit pinsel und vor allem ihr könnt
natürlich das ganze mit erdbeeren machen
etwa sind wirklich so mein favorit aber
können zb auch blaubeeren im team wären
oder was auch immer ihr möchtet hier
schon würden bestimmt auch gut passen
sagt man also
was soll man dazu sagen genial ungefähr
frischkäse ein eigentlich sagt er denn
murat immer es nicht so der frischkäse
falls jetzt auch hunger bekommen habt
dann geht auf meinen blogs - täter stets
noch mal ganz genau für euch und für
mich gehört es jetzt auch zu meinen
absoluten lieblings nach sehr einfach
gemacht nur einfach nochmal auf jeden
fall also viel spaß gemacht hat und bis
zum nächsten mal schön aber die schüssel
gehört es mir